Attorney General Jeff Sessions was in
the hot seat today testifying before the
House Judiciary Committee Republicans
wanted to know why the Justice
Department hasn't investigated Hillary
Clinton scandals and as for the
Democrats surprise surprise they spent
their time focusing on mr. sessions past
statements about meetings with wait for
it Russians and it's private
conversations with President Trump you
made statements that he did in fact at
the meeting I push back you know that I
can't be able to I'm in a position where
I miss you and not going to be able to
answer if I can't answer completely
Donald Trump ever ask you to pledge an
oath of loyalty to him no if Donald
Trump were to ask you to pledge loyalty
to him to take such an oath would you do
so well I don't know what a pledge of a
loyalty oath is I met with the
ambassador in my office with at least
two of my staff senior respected
Patriots Colonels retired in the Army
and mr. Tanaka improper occurred at all
once it for all can we answer the clam
once and for all answering the question
congressman I don't understand why you
won't take my answer joining us now for
reaction is a member of that House
Judiciary Committee Andy Biggs a
Republican from Arizona I often think
about you know what I would do if I
remember Congress and I had to be at
least hearings congressman but this kind
of took the cake I mean Jeff Sessions
sitting there and basically every five
seconds from a Democrat you're basically
lying senator sessions and journey
general sessions you really met with the
Russians are you really part of the
coalition you give us a sense inside
that room today no you're exactly right
so it showed that the the stark
difference between the Republicans who
are trying to get the Attorney General
to do something appointed special
counsel to investigate and the Democrats
who are they're fixated on trying to
paint him as some kind of lying collude
or with Russia I mean with their with no
evidence it's just amazing to me and by
the way we invited
Sheila jackson-lee on but apparently she
was involved in a late-night briefing on
the tax reform bill so maybe they're
gonna come all along with you guys on
tax rate it could happen yeah so she and
we vited a bunch of other Democrats
because he wanted to have both sides on
the show tonight so I have to say that
let's talk about that flashpoint today
and then we'll play the soundbite this
was Congressman Jim Jordan who was on
with us last night and I think this was
probably the most interesting moment at
today's hearing let's listen if you're
now just considering it I what's it
going to take to get a special counsel
we know that we know that former FBI
director James Comey misled the American
people in the summer 2016 when he called
the Clinton investigation a matter it's
obviously an investigation it would take
a factual basis that meets the standards
of the appointment of a special is that
that's what it looks like and I'm asking
you
doesn't that warrant in addition to all
the things we know about James Comey in
2016 doesn't that warrant naming a
second special counsel looks like is not
enough basis to appoint a special
counsel what's your sense here are you
on this special counsel bandwagon on
this because there's an argument against
special counsel that I find fairly
persuasive in this case I am because
you've got an attorney generals kind of
left left it away he stepped away from
it and we we have to get to the bottom
of this that we know that there's
conflicts of interest all in that AG's
office so we need a special prosecutor
special counsel in my opinion I think
Jim's right we've been waiting for a
long time and you know today yesterday
we get the notice saying hey we're
considering it after months of don't you
think that looks kind of like a tit for
tat I mean we got the we got the mother
investigation of Trump then it looks
like to some people that President Trump
is pressuring Congress to do a special
counsel to go after Hillary and Clinton
Foundation uranium one and Jeff Sessions
really isn't recused I don't think from
anything involving Hillary Clinton he's
recused himself from anything involving
the Russian investigation but I think
he's well within his right in this case
to appoint a terrific prosecutor with a
great team of assistant prosecutors to
do this job and then you
won't have the sprawling investigation
that goes on and on forever frankly
waste the taxpayers dollars and I don't
think it's necessary in this case
sessions can just appoint a great
prosecutor and do the real investigation
why do you need a whole whole merry band
of prosecutors waste our money well I
think you're right in the sense that the
Jeff Sessions could but he look who is
chief deputies are you got Ron
Rosenstein you've got a knock a Tory a
rod and you got Andrew McCabe still in
that office influencing things and and I
think walking away today I think many of
us said I don't know if Jim Attorney
General Sessions believes he has the
authority or if he doesn't have the
authority and that's why we kept coming
back to the same questions and so you
know we want to get this investigated
you know if it doesn't take one fine
congressman Biggs great to see you thank
you